[Music]
it's been four years since we last saw
toothless hiccup and the rest of our
favorite Vikings we are pumped about the
third installment in How to Train Your
Dragon franchise stay tuned to find out
all the deets about the new movie are
you a total movie buff subscribe to keep
up with all the four one one about your
favorite flicks now let's talk about
everything we know about how to train
your dragon 3 the hidden world our story
changed the world forever
in 2010 DreamWorks took the world by
storm with the release of How to Train
Your Dragon this movie based off the
book by Cressida Cowell was a huge hit
hiccup was the son of a Viking leader
but he's not exactly tough Viking
material he's a bit of a more sensitive
type and not really into the whole
pillage and plunder scene hiccups people
have been attacked by dragons for
generations and they hunt the creatures
he hunts his first dragon but when he
tries to finish the job he finds that he
cannot do it hiccup befriends the
injured a Night Fury dragon who he named
toothless he trains do this and learns
to ride him after building him a
prosthetic wing with the help of
toothless hiccup learns that an evil
dragon forces the other dragons to bring
offerings of livestock that's why all
the dragons attack hiccups village
toothless and hiccup saved the day and
soon all the Vikings have accepted
dragons and learned to train them for
years later DreamWorks released an
awesome sequel in fact How to Train Your
Dragon 2 is often considered to be the
best DreamWorks film in this movie a
crazy dude named Drago is trying to
build an army of dragons he has a
bewilder beast that can control smaller
dragons hiccup meets his long-lost
mother and he learns that he has spent
the last 20 years rescuing dragons from
Drago the bewildered beast hypnotizes
toothless who tries to attack hiccup but
ends up hitting hiccups dad instead we
were hit with all the feels when he cups
dad was gone so sad hiccup becomes the
new chieftain and frees toothless from
the control of the bewilder beast
however they defeat the evil dragon and
its master there's a ton of action and
humor packed into the first two movies
so we are very excited to get more of
that in the
film we've got all the info about how to
train your dragon the hidden world are
you as excited as we are
release date obviously the important
question is when do we get to see this
new movie seriously we can't wait
forever but the good news is there is
already a release date stats and it's
not that far away How to Train Your
Dragon three releases in theaters on
March 1st 2019 mark your calendars now
we will totally be there on opening day
will you while we wish it was released
like tomorrow or something we guess we
can wait after all dreamworks has a lot
to live up to from the first two movies
we know they're working hard to make it
perfect and now we have plenty of time
to re-watch the first two movies a few
dozen times
maybe that's just us the awesome cast is
back sometimes things change a lot in
the years between sequels there's always
the chance that the old voice actors may
not want to return but we are in luck
with How to Train Your Dragon 3 all of
your favorite characters are returning
along with the actors who originally
brought them to life hiccup looks a lot
older with his Viking beard in the new
trailer but Jay Baruchel is still
voicing him we can't imagine any other
voice being us perfect for hiccups
character as Jays he's been busy since
the last movie and as of the date of
this video he has five movies in the
works we're ecstatic he found time to be
hiccup again America Ferrera is back as
hiccups girlfriend Astrid we love Astrid
stuff but caring character she is all
about the girl power so she makes the
perfect Viking what has America been up
to since the second How to Train Your
Dragon movie
the former Ugly Betty star has been on
the TV show superstore since 2015
we can wait to have her bring Astrid
back in the new movie Kristen Wiig and
TJ Miller are also returning us the
hilarious Viking twins
ruffnut and tuffnut since stoic played
by Gerard Butler met his untimely end in
the last movie he will not be returning
to the last one late night host Craig
Ferguson will be back as clobber we also
picked up some amazing new characters in
How to Train Your Dragon 2 Cate
Blanchett played Valka hiccups mother
she will be back in the third film this
is what is to be a drag
we love that hiccup comes by his love of
dragons naturally it's totally awesome
that we'll get to know his mom even
better you might also remember Aaron's
from the second movie he was the guy he
was forced to bring dragons for dragos
army Eretz played by none other than Kit
Harington we'll also be back for How to
Train Your Dragon 3
he may know Kit Harington as Jon Snow
from Game of Thrones
Jon Snow he's king in the north
kid must be really into dragons
toothless finds love there's no doubt
about it
toothless is one of the most adorable
dragons in movie history hiccups loyal
steed is a rare dragon known as a Night
Fury but much like his human toothless
is a little awkward and he is more than
a little awkward in the trailer for the
new movie toothless meets a girl dragon
who looks a lot like him only instead of
being jet-black she is pure white in the
trailer Astrid calls her a light fury
whatever she is toothless is instantly
smitten he falls head-over-heels for
this pretty dragon or does he fall tails
over wings toothless is a little unsure
how to let this dragon know he's into
her and that's how a dragon is super
relatable
why are crushes so hard hiccup attempts
to teach him dragon mating moves but the
light fury looks mostly confused and
unimpressed
toothless may just have to impress her
with his awesome bravery instead we sure
hope toothless has a happy ending with
his dragon love we can't wait to see
this lovely light fury toothless has a
girlfriend
director dean deblois describes her as a
very rare very elusive and very wild she
sounds absolutely perfect for toothless
but she is also the agent of change for
toothless pulling him into his wild
dragon destiny that's going to be an
important plot point in the new film we
hope it doesn't permanently pull
toothless away from hiccup there's a new
villain hiccup starts to realize that
maybe humans and Dragons have different
destinies even though they can live
together in peace they live together in
a basically perfect world of Vikings and
Dragons and hiccup and toothless are
what hold the world together that as
toothless feels a call to his wild side
that perfect world starts to falter but
even as they are drawn apart humans and
Dragons have a new common enemy Grimm
elder grizzly is a
big game hunter and his game of choice
is dragon he is responsible for hunting
the night Furies like toothless nearly
into extinction
what a horrible dude he's obsessed with
hunting to the points that he's got some
seriously shady morals toothless is the
only Night Fury who grimille has not
hunted when hiccup refuses to hand over
toothless grimille vows to destroy
everything hiccup and toothless love ok
grimille that seems a bit dramatic don't
you think
hiccup tells his viking dragon utopia
that they must disappear from the map to
save themselves and that they have to
fight for the dragons freedom we can't
wait to see some awesome dragon battle
sequences Gribble is played by F Murray
Abraham and from what we've seen in the
trailer he is perfect for this ruthless
villain the actor won an Academy Award
for his role in Amadeus back in the 80s
he spent the last several years on the
show homeland grimille is vicious smart
and has a clear goal F Murray Abraham
calls him a perfect balance to goodness
in other words this dude is pure evil
he's definitely going to be a challenge
to hiccup and toothless we just hope we
don't lose any more beloved characters
like we did and How to Train Your Dragon
2 we don't know if we can handle that
sort of emotion again what is the hidden
world we don't have a ton of details
about the plot yet we know toothless
gets a girlfriend and we know who the
villain is but the new movie is called
the hidden world in the trailer we hear
hiccup described it as a hidden world of
dragons that sound epic sign us up how
will this hidden world play into this
plot is this where the light fury
disappears - when she vanishes into thin
air
will all the dragons go there so many
questions this is the end the How to
Train Your Dragon franchise will have
been running for nine years when the
third film comes out and while we wish
we could get a new adventure with
toothless and hiccup every few years it
seems that we just won't get it How to
Train Your Dragon the hidden world is
the end of the franchise the director
dean deblois has been very clear on this
point he wanted to give the story a
clear definitive end after all the
author of the books Cressida Cowell had
a crystal clear resolution to her
stories we can expect the same from the
new movie Cowell explained in her last
book why dragons are no longer around
although the storyline has changed a lot
for the movies
woahhh assures us we'll get an answer to
that question too
why aren't there dragons anymore could
they come back he promises that all
these loose ends will be tied up in a
nice neat bow for us wait a second does
that mean the story will end with all
the dragons disappearing in the trailer
hiccup tells toothless it's you and me
forever but is it is the Dragons destiny
to leave the human world
do they have to leave permanently to
escape grimille and if they can come
back is there a chance we could get
another movie we know two blue-eyes says
not but we've seen it happen to other
franchises we won't hold our breath
though the director seems pretty clear
about this being the end we're not going
to cry we're not going to cry it's a new
dreamworks era dreamworks has been
producing amazing animated films for a
really long time aunts was the first
DreamWorks Animation film way back in
1998 that means they've been making it
in movies for over 20 years and they've
given us some epic titles Shrek won an
Academy Award and let's not forget the
Madagascar and Kung Fu Panda franchises
those early films were hilarious and
light-hearted
more recently DreamWorks has given us
movies like trolls and home while all
these movies are a ton of fun and have
easy to love characters they often deal
with some really dark storylines How to
Train Your Dragon 2 was really the
turning point for DreamWorks to have
some more series drama field plots after
all we can't forget how hiccups dad met
his end at the hands of a bewitched
toothless that is seriously tragic and
left us totally shook then DreamWorks
gave us Kung Fu Panda 2 which was
basically about wiping out a whole race
of creatures
that's some crazy dark stuff that sounds
like it came out of history textbooks if
you get past the light-hearted
characters and trolls and home you'll
see some other serious messages
DreamWorks has taken some huge cinematic
risks mixing kids comedy with deeper
adult themes and that's part of the
reason we love them have a nice flight
How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world will be the first movie to be
released by DreamWorks since they have
had a major business change DreamWorks
Animation has left 20th Century Fox and
is now part of Comcast Corporation
that's a lot of boring business talk but
it could mean a lot of big changes for
the DreamWorks films we've come to love
the second How to Train Your Dragon
movie was a major turning point and now
the third one will set a new standard
under a new company we have no idea what
this means for movies in the future but
we are excited to find out we've never
been disappointed by DreamWorks yet this
new movie is going to be lit it seems
that How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world will be a turning point for
toothless hiccup and the company so it's
going to be epic we have so many
questions and we cannot wait until March
1st 2019 to see the new movie what are
you most excited about to see in How to
Train Your Dragon 3 who is your favorite
character don't be shy let us know in
the comments that's what we know about
how to train your dragon the hidden
world keep up with all the upcoming
movies by subscribing today and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up
[Music]
[Music]